في السعوديه دشنا وزير البيئه والمياه
والزراعه المهندس عبد الرحمن الفضلي شبكه
الشرق الاوسط لامراض الاحياء المائيه
اختارت الشبكه مختبر صحه وسلامه الاسماك
بجده ليكون مختبرا مرجعيا للدول الاعضاء
بالشبكه التي تضم البلدان المطله على
البحر الاحمر والخليج العربي وتشمل 14
دوله تعزيز صناعه الاستزراع المائي
والوقايه من امراض الاحياء المائيه من
ابرز المستهدفات هذه الشبكه كما تهدف الى
مساعده الدول الاعضاء على تطوير واستدامه
قطاع الاستزراع المائي وتشجيع الدراسات
والبحوث حول ممارسات تربيه الاحياء
المائيه والامراض وعلم الاوبيئه
المختبر سلامه الاسماك بجده ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد الحميد عبد
الواحد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه ااا من الرياض
حدثنا اكثر عن هذا المركز او هذا المختبر
مختبر سلامه الاسباك لماذا ايضا تم اختيار
هذا المختبر في هذا المشروع المهم
اهلا وسهلا بك وبالساده المشاهدين طبعا
نحن هنا في هذا المختبر الذي يضم فرقا
مختصه تعمل على مدار الساعه نعرف ان همم
التدشين اليوم الذي همم يعني تم برعايه
وزاره البيئه همم يعتبر حدث مهم على الاقل
في ما يتعلق يعني هذا القطاع همم وما
يتعلق كذلك ب- اا يعني حتى شبكه الشرق
الاوسط لي امراض الاحياء المائيه في
المملكه همم نعلم كذلك بان همم الاعتماد
الدولي من خلال منظمه الصحه العالميه
تحديدا صح الحيوانيه همم التي يعني تمثلت
بحضور مسؤولين همم في هذا المختبر طبعا
يوجد اكثر من غرفه يعني المختبر ليس عباره
عن غرفه واحده بتبيعه الحال همم يعني هو
منشاه اكثر منه همم يعني مختبر واحد
وبالتالي هناك اكثر من همم غرف مختبريه
يعمل فيها سعوديون وسع على مدار الساعه
لايه يعني
العمل بشكل متواصل كما تعلم نايف همم يعني
نريد ان نتعرف اكثر على كل ما يجري همم
يعني همم نستضيف الدكتور علي الشيخ الرئيس
التنفيذي للبرنامج الوطني لتطوير قطاع
الثروه الحيوانيه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور
دكتور ابتداء نريد ان نسال عن اهميه هذا
المختبر اهلا وسهلا ومرحب بكم في هذا
الحدث اليوم طبعا انا سميتها الصباح في
الورشه يوم تاريخ اليوم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في قطاع الثوره السمكيه انه همم
يتم
المختبر هذا كم مختبر مرجعي لامراض وصحه
الاسماك الى الاقليم كامل المنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وهذه النقطه طبعا جت بجهود سنوات
تراكميه من العمل
والبناء القدرات وكذلك الانظمه والتشريعات
الموجوده في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي
المختبرات خصوصا المرحله القادمه باذن
الله راح يكون عندنا تعاون مع الدول وثقت
في السعوديه همم
هذه الخبرات وكذلك بناء القدرات والانظمه
والشريعات مختبر هذا طبعا همم مختبر رئيسي
همم يعني همم تحليل همم الاسماك
والمكافحه الاوليه للامراض خصوصا تصاب في
كثير من الفيروسات والامراض والبكتيريا في
المختبر هنا بيكون فيه الكثير من
الاجراءات المبدايه والاستفاقيه لهذه
لمكافحه هذه الامراض
المسببات المرضيه للكائنات الحيه والتي
تنعكس بطبيعتها على الانسان لاحقا فلذلك
هنا مرحله اتباقيه همم لمكافحه هذه
الامراض المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
في هذا المجال المتقدمه في في بشكل واسع
همم الانظمه اللي تعمل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تستقي منها همم الدول الشقيقه
همم نفس البروتوكولات وتطبقها يوم التعاون
على على قدم النساء بين الدول الدكتور
يعني خلينا نقول ما هي الخطوه القادمه بعد
ما اصبح هذا المختبر مختبر اقليمي
من اليوم عندنا المختبر هذا رايكم تعقد في
دورات بناء قدرات لكل الدول المشاركه في
هذه الشبكه راح يكون عندنا تشريعات
والانظمه الموجوده تعمم وتشارك مع الدول
راح يكون من عندنا ارسال مدربين من
المختبر هذا للدول الاخرى بنوعيه الانظمه
الاجهزه
التحاليل همم طريقه الاداء عمليات الفحص
لسباقيه واللاحقه هذه كلها طبعا في
المرحله القادمه ان شاء الله باذن الله هي
ال- ال- همم الوجه المضيء لهذا مختبر طيب
فيما يتعلق خلينا نقول بالمساله همم
الصحيه انتم يعني اكيد انه عمل لكم مرتبطه
بشكل رئيسي بالاسماك وعموما كل ما يوجد من
الحيوانات في البحار كيف ممكن انتم تطورون
هذه العمليه طب انا اليوم نعمل همم في
الوزاره على ثقافه اسمها صحيحه الواحد
يتكلم عن جميع المنتجات اللي في همم
يستهلك همم الانسان
ناحيه السؤال الحيوانات او الاسماك او
كذلك النباتات في الصحه هذه مشتركه في
جميع المراحل سواء في مراحل البدائيه
التربويه او في النهائيه الانتاجيه فلذلك
هنعمل اليوم على برنامج اسمه الصحه
الواحده همم اليوم وزاره الصحه لديها هذا
بنفس الكنسه موجود فان شاء الله الحلقات
ما راح يكون عندنا الديمق قادمه لعمليات
المشتركه بين الانظمه والاجهزه في جميع
المختبرات بحول الله شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور على كل هذه التفاصيل يعني هذه
ابرز التفاصيل
ومتعليقات هذا المختبر الذي ابتداء من يوم
اصبح مختبر ان اقليميا ومرجعا هنا في
الشرق الاوسكار
سلامه الاسماك بجده ينضم علينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الواحد الحميد